all right guys
bang bang i've got a special treat i've
got jeff here with me thanks so much for
doing this sir
good morning or good afternoon your time
absolutely
uh let's jump right into your background
kind of what did you do before ggv
so i grew up in uh seattle uh moved to
the east coast in 1990 to go to college
up in new hampshire at dartmouth played
basketball for four years there
and then moved to silicon valley in 1995
i did a short stint in a ski town called
ketchum idaho in between
uh i learned a lot there and then i
moved to san francisco in 95
i worked in consulting for three years
of pwc in the us and hong kong so i got
my first kind of taste of working in
asia
95 96 and then i started my first tech
company in 1997 when i was 25 years old
started a software company called
quantum shift uh
we grew it from 0 to 30 million in sales
in three years which is awesome
uh the only the only sidebar to that is
we raised 125 million dollars along the
way and and we were going to go public
in 2000 and then the market cratered and
we got punched in the face and uh you
know as mike tyson says everybody has a
plan until you get punched in the face
and we got punched uh
so it just was it was brutal um and the
business we lost half our revenue in six
months and
and uh ended up kind of splitting up the
company and selling it i left in 2002 so
i started when i was 25 left when i was
30 walked away with nothing
uh you know at one point i was was
running a fairly valuable company and
walked away with zero so i learned a lot
got married started my syn company in
2003 we sold that to verisign which is a
public tech company
uh i then spent three years at verisign
and then i joined udv capital in
may of 2008 so i've been here for 13
years it's been great
ggv has uh one of the most interesting
foundations i think in terms of you guys
are a global venture capital firm
you manage i think it's five or six
billion dollars maybe talk a little bit
just about why
join ggb and then kind of how do you
think about the way you guys invest for
the themes you're looking at
yeah so we're um yeah you met so we're a
six and a half billion dollar global
venture capital firm we operate as one
team across the world so that's a unique
aspect of our business most funds
split it up and i'll have like an israel
fund to try to find a us fund we operate
as one team
we have about 90 people in the us
singapore beijing and shanghai
and we invest in india latin america
southeast asia
china and the u.s and what that allows
us to do
and i think you know similar to some
other global firms like ours whether
it's a black stone or a goldman sachs or
a dst
is see trends and themes that are
playing out globally
and have that lens you know we always
like to joke that there's only 330
million people in the us
there's 7.5 billion people globally so
if you can address that whole audience
and bet on themes whether it's a
digitization of healthcare
digital finance fintech smb tech
software
internet e-commerce you know why
wouldn't you want to bet on those trends
around the world
particularly if you can build up some
expertise and build a flywheel of
entrepreneurs and executives that can
help you grow in those industries and so
one good example we were an early
investor in alibaba group back in 2003
when it was a 10 million dollar company
and it was valued at about 200 million
before i joined by the way so when i say
we it's the royal we
but uh you know that experience of
watching alibaba grow into the world's
largest ecommerce platform
and oh by the way building relationships
with all of the executives inside of
that company as they went on to then
start and be part of other companies
we were able to fund other e-commerce
businesses around the world and today
you know i'm on the board of big
commerce which is a software company in
the us in the e-commerce space
my partner hans is on the board of wish
in poshmark we invested in peloton we
invested in a firm
we invested in square so just a whole
string of things that we've invested in
that category
all over the world and so that's our big
thesis is it's not about stage
it's about sector and themes and trends
and getting those right at a global
basis and if you get them right
you can back multiple billion dollar
companies all over the world yeah what's
so interesting to me here
is uh basically once you see it in one
area you really can then go and
capitalize it in other areas
how much of that is seeing the trend in
the united states and then kind of going
and finding it in other markets i think
that's kind of what we saw in the 2000s
and maybe into the beginning of the
2010s
or are you now seeing the reverse where
you might see a trend happening in
china or india or somewhere else and
then trying to find that happening here
in the us
yeah it's a great point so you know from
2000 to 2010 i think everybody thought
of the trend of things get basically
created in the us and then replicated
elsewhere
and that that's still happening to some
extent but with the internet population
and over a billion users on
on mobile phones in india china
you know africa southeast asia you're
seeing a lot of innovation happen in
those other markets and so there are
things happening like china for example
is
ahead of us on digital commerce right
they're ahead of us on e-commerce
you know over 50 of the retail market in
china is now e-commerce in the u.s as of
january it was 16
it obviously spiked in the last few
months so there are things that are
coming from
china and from from these other markets
that we're adopting and we're learning
from so you could you could argue like
you know you
i mean look at tick tock right that came
from from china
um so i think i think it's a little bit
of both and then it's just the the
innovation around the world with access
to capital flowing so freely now
when things do get created in one part
of the world they get they do get
replicated and and innovated in
different parts of the world so you're
seeing
you know tons of of healthcare
technology which is a
you know i think is amazing like think
about how many billions of people around
the world have never had access to good
healthcare
so if digitization of telemedicine
digital banking things like that
the faster that flows into these
emerging market economies the better in
my opinion but it's a little bit of both
yeah well i want to go through a couple
of the investments you guys have made
maybe you can just kind of tell us the
story of how you guys came across them
and i think we'll pull out some of the
themes and experiences and lessons
learned
the first is wish which is now a massive
shopping company maybe tell us that
story
yeah it's a great story because peter
peter who started the company and his
ceo today really saw
something that most people didn't see we
met peter in early 2014 and he was sort
of pivoting out of
an ad driven business and into an
e-commerce business and what peter saw
and subsequently what my my partner han
saw
was he was creating a mobile ecommerce
platform
for the mass consumer so you think about
in the us we have dollar general we have
dollar store we have kohl's we have
walmart
we have all these businesses which by
the way are
hundreds of billions in annual sales
they cater to
you know the mass market consumer which
would sort of be like
middle income and and down and the
venture capital community at that time
was predominantly
catering to upper income consumers and
saying gee i want to target iphone users
you know average hotel household income
of 100k a year that's a great
demographic they're going to spend a ton
of money on the internet
and the thing that han saw in 2014 was
similar to what taobao has done in china
and taobao is part of alibaba it's the
largest ecommerce platform in the world
cater to the mass market right offer
everything from you know two dollar
products to 200
products but the the high end actually
took a lot more time right now today we
have open door and real estate and
carvana and cars and
the high end is actually getting
discovered but peter built a
you know 10 billion dollar plus company
on the back
of the kind of middle to low end
consumer
and that market is enormous right i mean
he calls it amazon subprime so these are
people who who
really aren't even at the point in their
life or their career where they can
afford to shop on amazon which actually
has doesn't have the cheapest product
i think that that idea of catering to
the mass market and oh by the way a huge
percentage of their businesses outside
the u.s
so understanding that people around the
world want to shop not everybody makes a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
sends their kids to private school in
atherton
is a unique aspect of our business right
to be able to see beyond
the demographic that high-end
demographic that a lot of venture
capitalists and investors play in
and of course now you've got companies
like a firm you've got
obviously square you've got a lot of
companies that have started to go after
that more mass-market consumer
but that's a relatively recent trend
even the smb tech economy that square
and
you know big commerce and shopify are
playing in that really started in 2010
before that
nobody in tech really went after smb or
even the mass market consumer that's a
relatively recent trend
yeah you also invested in coinbase which
is
uh kind of a counter trend um you know
when that company started there was
nobody really talking about bitcoin or
cryptocurrency especially not in the
mainstream media
kind of talk about where did you guys
see that one and kind of what was the
thesis
yeah i think you know at the time this
was probably 2016 or 17.
um you know one of the things when we
talk about being sector focused and
betting on trends obviously crypto
at the time was becoming a very big
trend in a very big topic and so we
spent some time doing some research
trying to figure
out understand the technology understand
how it could play out obviously we had a
global point of view so we saw what was
happening in singapore and hong kong and
china
in addition to the us and we you know to
be fair we were you have folks like
usv and andreessen horowitz and and
and other funds that were ahead of the
curve on that and and did very well
investing in bitcoin and elsewhere so we
weren't early
to that trend but you know we we made a
couple of small investments in some new
projects and said look one of the things
we do believe will happen if bitcoin and
crypto are here to stay is coinbase will
do very well
and i think that turned out to be that
turned out to be a good bad i wish we
had invested more
famous last words of every every
investor um but you know we met with
brian just we're super impressed with
him
uh the management team that he's got
there his approach to taking like a
you know a very professionalized
regulated
point of view in an industry that at the
time if you remember was not
it was sort of like anti-regulation and
so for him to sort of
you know take an approach where he said
look i assume this is going to be
regulated by the sec i assume we're
going to have to comply with u.s banking
laws
i think was very smart and was ahead of
the time and now you've got other
exchanges that have done the same thing
but
you know and he's gone on to build i
think what will be a very valuable
company
yeah it's uh i think we're seeing a lot
of companies who took the opposite
approach right now
kind of paying for those sins right
whether it's regulators stepping in
or just kind of all sorts of issues um
so i i tend to agree that that approach
which which by the way and you know was
such
was so short-sighted right like like the
the the economy is the
if you read like any book on politics
politics and money are very tied
together right
so you know one of the reasons the eu
broke up was those countries lost
control of their own currency
right greece suddenly realized it had a
huge problem when it couldn't value its
own currency and so
the ability to sort of control currency
and manage the flow of monetary supplier
around the world now we're in a little
bit of a weird situation right now where
the u.s is printing money like drunken
sailors
but that is a huge part of the way
politics and the economy work and so i
think
i would love to see over time crypto and
bitcoin because of the way the
technology works and sort of
democratizing access to it
i think it'd be great to have it be part
of the economy and part of the monetary
system over time
but that's not going to happen outside
of government yeah i just don't believe
it will
i i tend to agree with you another
company that is kind of going up against
some incumbents and trying to disrupt
things is lambda school
uh there's obviously some regulation
involved there but also just some
innovation kind of
what was that story so
you know one of the things i've learned
adventure over time is when you get
when you get people that are going after
really big market opportunities
with asymmetric ideas and i'll give you
a couple examples
airbnb asymmetric idea people are going
to sleep on couches
people were like what the that's the
dumbest thing i've ever heard of
but in hindsight we look at it and
they're now bigger than marriott and
hyatt and
you know you look at uber right or lyft
like asymmetric idea going after a
massive existing industry
and those businesses could be zeros like
i think that's the thing when people are
critical of like an elon musk or a magic
leap or whatever it's like
if you don't try the asymmetric idea you
never change the industry and so when
they don't work people think you're an
idiot
but when they do work people are like oh
yeah of course airbnb it's like go talk
to brian and joe and nate 10 years ago
like nobody thought that was an obvious
idea
and i kind of i i would put austin in
that same category like he's trying to
change the way the education system
works and he's saying
why should i have to spend 200 grand to
go get a cs degree at stanford to get a
job at google like this that just
doesn't make any sense by the way when i
come out of it i owe 200 grand i owe
like the way the whole system works is
the individual takes all the risk
and so what he did was basically created
this concept he didn't really create the
concept but he capitalized on the
concept of the isa
which is basically saying look i'll
cover the cost of you getting educated
and i'll take the bet that you're going
to get a job and when you do get a job
pay me back but it's like the opposite
of the student loan model which by the
way we now have like one of the biggest
crisis in america with all these people
carrying student loans
imagine if all those people had isas the
market would be
completely different and so you know i
i think it's a good trend and you're
seeing some like purdue has opted it has
adopted an isa model
so what austin's really trying to do is
one get rid of the student loan problem
and two democratize access to that if
you're a barista at starbucks
and you want to get a cs degree and go
get a job at google or amazon or
facebook
you can do that through lambda school
now you have to work your ass off and
it's hard
one of the things that he figured out
along the way you got to make it hard
if i'm going to take the risk on you to
get a job i've got to make it hard to
ensure that you've got the
the grit to actually work your ass off
and go get that job and do well once you
have that job and so there's this
really kind of mutually beneficial
relationship where like i need you to
work hard to get the job and when you do
you'll pay me back and so um it's just
you know it's one of these asymmetric
bets in a huge category if he's right
it's going to be a
you know it's going to be a massive
airbnb square type company but it's a
really hard business to build
and by the way you're going after an
industry where there's a lot of
entrenched interests who don't want you
to succeed
and so when you see negative media
coverage or
commentary about his business model
oftentimes that comes from sources that
may have an entrenched interest in in
seeing his business not succeed but
you know one of the things that i i
always tell people like i have the best
job in the world
one of the reasons is i get to take
risks on people like austin and say
hey if you get this right it's a 10 20
30 40 billion dollar company and by the
way it changes our system
and if you get it wrong that's a bummer
but that's what we get paid to do
it would suck if it's if it's a zero but
like that's our job
go take those risks and try and fund
those ideas that can change these
change these markets and then you know
just like
i mean whether it's austin or garrett
lord at handshake or lyric slice or
you know any of the people that we back
like these people are incredible like
super human
type people and they're not all elon
musk who's the superhuman of superhumans
but it's just incredibly inspiring to
meet with these people that are
literally creating the jobs
that are powering our country absolutely
you mentioned uh you mentioned slice
and i know that you guys have this big
thesis around
smb tech maybe talk a little bit about
that thesis in general and then we can
use slice as an example
so if you look back and i wrote i wrote
a post about this uh a few years ago if
you look back
to call 10 years ago there was basically
one company in smb tech that was into it
and and today there's probably 40
companies that we would put into that
bucket that are valued at about half a
half a trillion dollars shopify is
probably the most obvious example it's
valued at 100 billion
but you've got wix and square and ring
central and 8x8 and big commerce and
there's a whole bunch of companies that
their entire universe is powering
small business and by the way in small
business 60 percent of america works for
a small business
it's 40 us gdp so we need small business
to be successful
and that whole economy was created for
three reasons one
aws aws launched in 2005 so suddenly
made it cheap and easy to power
computing you didn't have to host your
own servers
two you had the iphone so your typical
small business owner circa 2008 didn't
have a computer with an internet
connection in their shop
they got an iphone and all of a sudden
they did right and the third thing was
the integration of fintech right so
stripe and braintree launched around
that same time frame
those three factors came together to
make it feasible to serve a small
business customer
for 100 or 200 a month in a way that you
couldn't do
five years earlier and that has now
powered a whole generation of companies
that are being built on
on that technology and you know if you
just look at those companies over the
last 12 to 18 months they've been
ripping
right as a as an investor if you own
that index of companies you've done very
very very well
and the reason is people have figured
out that when our economy reboots we
come out of coronavirus and the economy
reboots i just wrote a post called the
you know the small business economy will
power the reboot of the economy it'll be
powered by technology
when we come out of that small business
is going to power it has to
part of it is out of necessity as of
today there are 40 percent more
more applications for new businesses in
our country than there were a year ago
so one year ago today same same genre
same
and by the way we were in a booming
economy a year ago 40 more people have
applied for new
new companies this year the reason is
obviously a lot of them lost their job
which is
not good the positive out of that is a
lot of those folks will go on and never
go back and and get a normal job again
they'll have some great small business
and that business will be built on
technology they'll have a website on wix
they'll have you know pos with square
they'll use marketing from hubspot
they'll have a phone system from
ringcentral
so those companies i just think are not
only hugely valuable today but have an
extremely bright future
as that as that 40 of us gdp
more and more of those companies move on
to technology and so you
you mentioned slice which is near and
dear to my heart because i love pizza i
know you do too and one of my life's
missions is to get you off of dominoes
and onto great local pizza
but you know if you look at what aalir
has done with slice
and he's third generation pizza right he
grew up in a pizza family he eats
breathes
he was probably instead of a binky in
his mouth he probably had pepperoni
but like what he saw was pizza merchants
you had the rise of dominoes which was
basically
building a tech stack now 80 of domino's
orders are mobile and web
your average small business merchant in
the pizza industry and by the way
there's 32 000 in america
had zero technology most of them don't
even have a point of sale system and so
lira said i'm gonna go build that
technology
for them the mobile and web ordering and
then eventually
i'll be able to power their business
with marketing
and capital and a whole bunch of other
resources to help them grow
just like domino's helps its franchisees
grow so
that business i think i think we
publicly announced the other day is now
eclipsed a billion in sales uh and all
of those are sales going to small and
local merchants
but what's great about that is the
momentum in that business aalir won't
like me saying this but i bet you will
eclipse 2 billion within 12 months
but it took 10 years to get to the first
billion the next you know the next
billion will take 12 months
which is how a lot of these businesses
work so it's just it's a really cool
story he's doing amazing things for
small merchants
and um yeah and a company we're really
proud of and what's so interesting
about slice right it's not only one a
fantastic idea to from an execution
standpoint they've obviously done a
great
job but three is uh it's very similar to
shopify's like arm the rebels
right like basically give the tools to
the people who are going up against the
incumbents
and he doesn't say it right but it's
basically what he's doing for these
uh local pizzerias is saying hey look
you don't have the ability to ever match
from a technology standpoint what these
large people are doing
um and what's really interesting i was
thinking through it the other day is uh
there's a starbucks uh around the corner
from me in new york right and everyone's
always like all the big corporation
and i was in there and it's actually a
franchise-owned one and so this is you
know literally the husband and the wife
are working on like a sunday morning you
know
the whole thing and so they have a very
different kind of entrepreneurship
experience just because they've got
starbucks behind them right they've got
marketing taken care of they've got a
technology stack they've got a lot of
the the systems in place
but it's not to run a business right
they still have to try to get people to
come in
and and you can just tell like that
starbucks in particular has certain
touches to it that maybe yeah it feels
authentic probably feels
right it's just a little different right
and frankly it's um it's the belief that
like that person
cares probably more than the manager at
the corporate uh uh store
now what slice seems to be doing is the
exact same thing
it's just empowering everything it's
just not under one brand right but it's
saying hey we're gonna give you all the
same things we're gonna give you the
systems we're gonna give you the
technology we're gonna help you with
marketing like
we're gonna do everything that if you
were a franchisee
would get only now you can do it under
your own brand you own your own business
and we're just simply a vendor right
yeah and you capture the majority of the
economics you're not paying a franchise
fee to start you're not paying royalty
so lyric calls out the reverse franchise
right so it's sort of like
sort of like the way uber approached the
transportation industry and said look we
don't need to own
the drivers we're going to let them know
in their own business and help them
generate
cash flow so you know yeah we're going
to existing merchants or new merchants
powering their business with technology
we're also a marketplace so we drive you
know last night we ordered a slice in my
house we ordered from a
a local merchant called bellaroma i've
never been in their store
but i go on slice every few weeks and we
place an order and of course by four
kids we always have friends over so eat
a lot of pizza
so it's a marketplace it's also a
technology
element as well and i think that you
know one of the hidden secrets of the
whole food delivery
industry is you know doordash ubereats
uh grubhub those guys take as much as 25
or 30 percent of the order value
that does not work for merchants i mean
the hidden secret of that industry is
merchants
your average restaurant merchant nets
five percent at the end of the year
so how can you pay out 30 to somebody
who's delivering the food
you just can't and so what we're seeing
now is a gradual transition of those
merchants off of those third-party
delivery
platforms onto slice and i think that's
a trend that you'll see for the next few
years and
and you know i think slice will be a
very big company but one of the things i
love about it is
elira is authentic he's not some guy who
was in business school was like oh the
pizza industry is a big
industry i'm gonna go build some
technology he is like like you walk into
a pizzeria with a lear
they're freaking they're like hugging
him and bringing him the special and you
know
he's he's he's one of them and and so
yeah that back to your point about the
arm the rebels
we've got um slice in that space we've
got big commerce and e-commerce we've
got brightwill in the pre-k education
space
i backed a company called belong home
was doing it in the residential
uh real estate space so this whole idea
of like arm the small business merchant
to help them compete with the big guy
i think he's super powerful and it's
also i mean one of the challenges we're
gonna have coming out of this economy
we're in right now is
you've got your starbucks your shake
shack your chipotle
your um you know whatever that have that
have
cash right so your your shake shack with
a billion dollars in their balance sheet
they can do things in terms of
transforming their restaurants into
pickup and delivery and
and take away that you know your average
small merchant can and so we got to find
a way
and it's a combination of not only
technology but capital and one of the
things we've lost in our country
is the small regional banks you know the
wells fargo and bfas have gobbled up all
the small regional banks
so the guy that used to sit down the
street and lend uri money when we wanted
to start a business is gone
what you're seeing is that get replaced
with square capital
you know we'll eventually have slice
capital uh shopify has shopify capital
so you're seeing the technology
companies
create a financing arm or partner with a
third party to offer financing these
merchants so that is a super positive
trend
yeah one of the other trends that uh
you've been pretty um
adamant about and i think founders are
starting to kind of wake up to and i
know that there's a couple of other
uh venture capitalists in uh in silicon
valley now that are voicing
uh hey this was a horrible idea was this
idea of like staying private long
right and uh i know that you've been a
big proponent many of your companies
uh have gone public earlier than you
know kind of the trend
talk a little bit just about how you've
thought about private companies getting
into the public markets are there
certain thresholds or kind of milestones
that okay now is a good time to start
thinking about that and then just what
the advantages of being a publicly
traded company are versus a private
company yeah so i i am a big believer
i think companies should be going public
earlier if you look at back in the 90s
the average company going
public had about a half a billion dollar
market cap 500 million i mean amazon's
marketing capital went public was 500
million
so the argument that you can't go public
as a small company and be successful
i just like there's just no data to
support that uh one of the greatest
companies of all time went public at 500
so
um and so then we got into this mode you
know over the last five to seven years
partially because of the massive influx
of capital from firms like softbank
saying to entrepreneurs hey don't go
public i'll give you 500 million dollars
just continue to grow as a private
company and look there was some there
was some validity to that right it was
easy to take the money
it didn't require a lot of of effort um
it didn't require a lot of disclosure
you know by the way you didn't have to
comply with public company record
reporting and accounting requirements
and it is you know it's a post-0809
reform it's a two three million dollar
effort to go public so it's not trivial
it's not cheap
but the flip side of that is i think
what it did was it also fostered
a lot a lot of undisciplined growth
so people took that capital and spent it
in ways that they probably wouldn't have
if they had had a public border
public shareholders and frankly eroded a
lot of value and took on a lot more
dilution than they needed to
and that you know that doesn't help us
as shareholders it doesn't help the
founders
and i think a lot of people in hindsight
are looking back and saying gosh i
probably could have built this company
with two or three hundred million less
and oh by the way be public today and
trading in a really healthy multiple if
i had just kind of taken the time to put
in place all those pieces along the way
so you know look we're very lucky we've
had eight companies go public in the
last 12 months we've got another four or
five that'll get out in the next five or
six months
those are companies that we invested in
you know six to nine years ago and have
spent the last 12 to 18 months
preparing to be public companies and
there are things you have to do you need
an audit chair on your board you need
you know you need audits from a big for
accounting firm you need
investor relations and kind of
accounting and finance infrastructure
internally they can handle it
but i think i just think it builds more
disciplined companies and and i don't
that where the narrative comes from of
like it sucks to be public like i'm on
the board of a public company
we've got lots of i don't talk to any
public ceos they're like yeah it really
sucks to be running this 20 billion
dollar company like
it's just it's just a false narrative
and so i i hope that trend continues you
know the one
the one wrinkle in the conversation
right now is the whole spac trend
uh and whether we will have some
companies that go public prematurely
that otherwise wouldn't have gone public
through the normal ipo process and i
think that could color people's
you know say oh gosh this company didn't
do well as a public company it's like
well
they kind of took an unconventional path
to get there we have a process set up
where bank that's the
that's the company now we we could use
some better uh technology in the pricing
methodology for ipos which bill gurley's
talked quite extensively about
but i just think if that trend reverses
and we see companies go public
earlier uh it'll be better for everybody
it's better for shareholders it's better
for the founders it's way better for
employees
giving your employees liquidity sooner
is better than later
uh and then the other thing that's good
for is economy like letting more
people participate in the increase of
value of these companies
earlier is a good thing right if i can
take a company public at two billion
like square
or 200 i think 2.9 when it went out and
it goes to 70. think about all the
people that have benefited from the rise
in value of square
versus square staying private for you
know five years and being worth 50
billion
and then only increasing in value and 20
billion and the public markets capturing
that value so i just
it's just it's just good all around and
oh by the way as a public company you
put permanent capital on your balance
sheet
you lock in job creation for decades to
come
it's just good for the economy overall
and we've also seen i think some
companies that tried to go through the
traditional ipo process and kind of fall
apart
under the scrutiny right and so we work
exactly and so i think that part of it
is like uh
the spac specs definitely help people
get there earlier and quicker and
cheaper and all this stuff but
there is something to be said about the
process works
in terms of making sure that the best
companies that are structured the right
way
get out into the market and i think that
that's one of the things that people
always forget is like the stock market
is
uh is a pretty good referee right yes
sure it gets inflated at times like that
was my point when people were talking
about a bubble a year ago
i said look at wework the market was
efficient it didn't get public
people realized it wasn't what they
thought it was and
um you know the other the other side of
that is i do think there are some specs
that will be successful
just like just just like ipos just like
anything else
i think there's a handful of managers
you know you look at what chamoth and
adam are doing you look at what marcus
dodd is doing at dragonair
right gerschner at altimeter i mean
there's a handful of people who are
professional investors that know what
they're doing
who i think will find great companies to
to take public
then there are another you know the
other 80 90 percent that i just
i just don't i don't think there are
that many great private companies
they're going to choose out as an option
so
i do think there's a little bit of
investor arbitrage there for your
listeners i do think if you pick good
managers
and you you can buy uh a a spa
buy shares in a spac before a deal gets
announced if it's a high quality manager
you can make some money yeah absolutely
uh one of the ideas that you've had
uh if we switch to kind of just silicon
valley in general uh is this idea of the
resilience of silicon valley and how
that's changed over the last kind of two
decades or so maybe
explain kind of your thought process
there and how you see that
well look this has been a tough year i
mean
you know pick your demographic right if
you work in a factory and you got laid
off if you're a kid that's not getting
to go to school right now if you work in
a tech company and you're working from
home like
it's been a rough year and i think um
you know one of my hopes is that mental
health becomes sort of a more
acceptable topic for people to talk
about because it's a very real issue
that i think this year in particular i
think we're gonna have some lasting
effects
from what we're going through right now
but having said that
what i have seen in our portfolio
companies in particular
is is incredible and i you know i was
here for the dotcom bubble
911 i was here for 00809 and those were
like
big punches where people went down for a
while like companies laid off staff
you felt like you were in a recession
and what i think we saw this year was
you know tech companies in particular
rebound very quickly uh one they were
prepared for it
so the ceo said okay i got a pandemic
i'm gonna deal with it
very compassionate about dealing with
their employees which i just we took a
lot of a lot of pride and even big
companies like salesforce and twitter
and facebook
um that did the same thing and then i
think people were
you know we we're in an age today where
we have zoom we have slack we have
you know messaging and iphones and all
this technology i mean can you imagine
if this happened 10 years ago
you and i wouldn't be having this
conversation like there was no there was
no zoom we would have to set up some
kind of weird like cisco webex and
so we kind of take for granted how
seamlessly we all transition into this
work from home mode
but i've just been really heartwarmed
you know look at all the companies that
have come out and announced very pro
you know hey take time off for your kids
take time to teach your kids take time
to help your kids with school
it just feels like to me people have
been pretty compassionate
and then just resilient and one of the
reasons why i think the market has
bounced back for tech stocks so quickly
is a lot of people are seeing what i'm
seeing which is in fact i tweeted out
this morning a a chart that ryan dennehy
one of our ceos tweeted out may
where he said i'm predicting the nike
recovery and it was like the the schwoof
logo where like
you know q2 was bad and then boom things
took off and that's what we're seeing
you know for the majority of our
companies q3 was a record quarter
and q4 is looking really really good so
i'm
i'm very optimistic heading into next
year we obviously have some huge
challenges as a country
but you know i'll tell you what we're
seeing between the lines tech companies
are doing well
a lot of small businesses are doing well
right try to buy a used car try to buy a
bike try to buy an rv try to buy a boat
try to
you know try there's a segment of the
economy that is booming
you've got obviously got a segment like
travel and some others that are not
doing well
but i'm i'm pretty optimistic heading
into next year
yeah i want to move kind of around the
world and a couple of other geographies
what are you seeing in
india uh and china specifically so india
is one of those markets where people
have been predicting a boom for
20 years and um
you know the the country one of the
things
people compare china and india and you
really had two very approach different
approaches over the last 20 years china
took a very pro-capitalism
government helping to drive the economy
approach india
did not do as much of that and so one of
the reasons why we're bullish on india
today versus maybe five or ten years ago
is you have reliance geo that has been
rolling out this
basically free uh wireless network all
across the country and literally
hundreds of millions of people
coming into the wireless economy that
were not there
a year or two ago and so that's an
unlock that not a lot of people outside
the country understand
but if you look at the money that's
going in you know there's literally been
billions and billions and billions of
dollars that have gone
got into reliance jio from u.s companies
as well as other companies
that is a signal of what's coming and we
believe that that is going to unlock a
whole new
part of the indian economy with
telemedicine
you know digital finance e-commerce all
the pieces of the puzzle that have been
thriving in our economy and in china
and so we're we're very optimistic about
about the road ahead partially because
of that
i think in china um you know the
interesting thing about china obviously
they were hit with the coronavirus in
january
but their economy today is basically
back right kids are in school
people are dining out um travel has
rebounded back to pre-pandemic levels
obviously they took a very aggressive
approach to how they dealt with
with the pandemic much more aggressive
than we did but it worked
and so one of the reasons why i'm
optimistic about the u.s is i think
eventually we didn't take that approach
but i am confident that eventually we
will beat it and when we do
i think you're going to see a booming
economy in the u.s right i mean think
about all you and i we're going to be
going to sporting events and concerts
and traveling and like
the amount of money that's going to be
unlocked in our our economy next year or
in 22
uh you know hopefully it's next year i
think it's gonna be pretty incredible so
we already see that in china
and you know my advice for investors
generally is if you don't have the long
position in some international equities
that have exposure to china you should
like it's it's it's going to be the
world's largest economy there's a lot of
reasons why it will continue to thrive
you've got entire categories like
healthcare that are still really early
in that market and there's just so much
room for innovation that
it's just as smart to have some
allocation there absolutely
we recently saw paystack a company in
nigeria
on the continent of africa get acquired
by stripe what what are you guys seeing
in any of the african countries
so we to be fair we don't have a
presence there um
and frankly don't you know it's just
like we always tell rlps like we've got
90 people in the firm six gps covering
the markets we cover is a lot trying to
add a new one would be hard
but there are some uh i interviewed maya
who runs ingress capital
um amazing i did a live podcast with her
she's incredible
she's one of the venture capitalists
that's doing a lot of cool things in
africa so
and she shared i highly recommend listen
to it because she shared some amazing
stats with me i think something like
uh 50 or 60 of the population in africa
is
under the age of 35 like unbelievable so
if you just assume
that that demographic is gonna have
access to mobile devices and eventually
have
rising incomes that is a pretty
compelling market to be and that's just
not one
we're just not there today but
definitely listen to the podcast of maya
she's incredible one of the smartest
people i've ever listened to period
but in particular on africa yeah that's
awesome
um you've been investing for a long time
uh both in the public and private
markets
uh what would you say are your biggest
lessons learned over the years
either by your biggest wins or your
biggest losses yeah
you know it's funny um one of my biggest
lessons learned is
when the market goes down it will
eventually go up
and i remember i was talking to ryan
dennehy back in march i think it was
like march 15th or 14th or 16th
and you know we were sort of having a
question about layoffs and
raising capital and everybody was pretty
panicked at the time if you remember in
our country
and i said look ryan i don't know
whether this pandemic lasts for three
months or three years
but i do know on the other side things
are going to be good
now i don't know if that's 2025 or
june but based on what i saw in 0809
and what i saw in 2001 on the other side
the u.s
and like i'm not the only one to say
this warren buffett said it don't bite
against the american economy
but so i invested more money in march
than i've invested in the last five
years combined
now i didn't know when it would pay off
it turned out to pay out paid off very
quickly but that was a lesson that i
learned from mo 809
i didn't have any money in oh 809 but
you know if you just look at the cloud
space
which is you know salesforce and others
there's been 4 trillion dollars of
market value created in the last 10
years in the cloud space
since 2009 so if you just threw a dart
at the wall and invested in every
software company that was public in 2009
and bought every ipo since then
you'd be one of the richest people on
the planet so i
i think that lesson is super informative
right just don't bet against the
american economy pick
sectors and trends that you think have a
5-10 year horizon and invest in them and
don't try and time the market that's
number one
back to your point about bitcoin right
bitcoin peaks 20 000
dropped it's back at 11. if you dollar
cost average then you made money i heard
you telling jim kramer that same thing
happens in the market and so if you have
names you like or companies you like or
trends that you believe in
buy those equities and when they drop
add a little bit more right you don't
have to go
all in day one but you know like i've
owned salesforce since it went public
you know i wish i owed more i think i
only put in like fifteen hundred dollars
because i didn't have a lot of money
back then
but it's been a good one to own and so
if you you know and there are companies
coming public today
that are still early in their life cycle
right you look at a twilio or a square
or an octa and those are sort of four or
five years ago though there are versions
of those companies coming public today
that investors can buy
and say look it might look really
expensive today if it drops
because of you know election turmoil or
market or maybe i'll add some more
but over time you'll make money in the
long run buying those companies and in
particular i'm super bullish on on
software um
you know just go and if you if you want
to just be simple go long cubeq and wcld
right wisdom cloud just tracks the the
bessemer software index qqq obviously is
the nasdaq
just buy those two things you'll make
money over the next 10 years um
and then the last one i think we've all
learned as investors is let your winners
run
i mean the the value creation that has
happened
post ipo for tech companies over the
last decade is just astonishing
right eighty percent of the value for
companies happens post ipo so a lot of
people a lot of people in the venture
industry
used to distribute at the lockup right
six months after company goes public
lock up expires they distribute all
their shares and then all the value gets
created
and so what a lot of venture firms have
learned is hey let's not distribute the
lockup let's maybe take our time because
so much value is going to get created
post ipo because companies put capital
on their balance sheet
growth rates in many cases are
accelerating i tweeted out yesterday
growth rates are actually accelerating
for software companies
and then they get better the branding
gets stronger they get better and then
if you look at like what jeff lawson's
done at twilio jeff has been using his
currency
to acquire companies he acquired
sendgrid and then he made another
acquisition just recently
so and you know he's building a
powerhouse i mean i'm super long twilio
it's one of my largest positions it has
been
almost since company went public i
believe in him i believe in the market
they're in and then i see him making
moves that say okay
he's not going to just sit back and sit
on his ass and watch the stock price go
up he's going to be aggressive and try
and build a
a category defining company there are
others like that that are coming to
market
and i just think you know like i was
telling our i had a bunch of
conversations with our lps recently and
they said what do you think the next
five years looks like and i said guys i
have to be honest with you i've been
here for 25 years
it's hard to not be the most bullish
i've ever been
on investing in technology like you talk
about coming out of an economic
pandemic you look at the smb tech boom
you look at the rise of of incomes
around the world
you look at digital banking digital cash
uh digital health care like all these
incredible trends
and then oh by the way there's going to
be a whole class of entrepreneurs that
spin up new kinds of companies out of
this pandemic that we haven't even
thought of yet
like how how can you not be bullish
right now
yeah and i think that it's uh really the
pandemic has just accelerated trends
that were already underway
right it was like all this technology
stuff people knew hey this is going to
be valuable
but you're literally just seeing people
now forced to adopt it
and that's part of the acceleration in
the growth trends right but it's also
uh i think now what you're doing is it's
kind of the creativity comes out of
constraints
right and so people are being forced to
hey i got to get a job right i got to
solve
one of my problems and that's where you
see a bunch of company creation as well
yeah and think about all the actions
like
people tried telemedicine for the first
time right we went from like five
percent of people that tried
telemedicine to the 40
in 90 days why because they couldn't go
to the doctor right you had
people who um you know the e-commerce
penetration the us went from 16 to 40
like why because people couldn't go into
stores you know you have think about all
the people who bought
home fitness equipment a peloton or a
tunnel or
whatever like some of them will lose an
interest
post pandemic and say yeah i'm gonna go
back to a 24-hour fitness but a lot of
them won't a very high percentage of
them won't say hey you know what i love
working at home
you're gonna have a whole new category
of entrepreneurs in the fitness category
i believe
right yoga instructors and fitness
instructors who are like why am i why am
i making 15 bucks an hour to go teach it
a fitness shop when i can teach my own
classes on zoom and make
10 grand a month but like there's a
there's an entire economy of
entrepreneurs that are going to sprout
up
to your point out of necessity like they
didn't have a choice like it sucks
we had to shock our economy the way we
did and it's been brutal
devastating but i think out of it
there's a whole wave of entrepreneurship
that's going to just be
back to that point i made earlier 40
more new business applications this year
than last year like that's crazy
that's that's astonishing you've got a
shirt on that says go long
and uh that couldn't be a more fitting
uh thought
i think uh kind of mantra given uh your
bullishness but but i think that the
key here really is the data supports a
lot of this and
um if you kind of believe that humans
will
constantly improve and push forward the
innovation
like being long is the right way to look
at
every sector yeah and and and i think
it's you know we
we have these shirts because we tell
entrepreneurs we want to go long right
we want to back entrepreneurs that want
to build
you know enduring companies that will be
very large but i think the same thing's
true in the market right i had a friend
of mine text me last week he's like hey
you think i should sell my zoom it's had
a big run i'm like
i don't know i'm not selling i'm super
bullish on eric i think the market
they're in is way bigger than people
think and i think he'll innovate in ways
that people haven't thought of and then
of course this week they came out and
announced a whole platform with zaps
and you could see an entire economy you
know some people are comparing it to the
iphone app store
like what if what if he creates the next
iteration of the iphone app store and it
becomes a trillion dollar company
right i mean how many people sold amazon
at 100 billion and we're like gosh this
thing is
it's crazy i mean you can't build a 100
billion dollar retailer because they
didn't see
aws coming well aws alone is worth a
trillion dollars
today so i just think when you when you
are along with these exceptional
entrepreneurs who are willing to take
risks and you give them
capital right they once they go public
they have capital to work with
holy crap hold those positions i mean
unless you have to sell
you know and in particular if tax rates
go up and you're paying a higher tax
rate to sell than you are today
i think you're going to see a lot of
people owning these these names for
years and making a lot of money in tech
stocks i just
multiples could compress but like we
also have to remember like in the
software space everybody goes oh my god
the multiples are crazy i'm like
well yeah the multiples are based on the
forecast and the forecasts are low
they're all beating the numbers so if
you go back and adjust those multiples
they don't look that crazy
so and then just to think about the
upside of the economy over the next few
years of course we have like
you know geopolitical risks there's
currency risk we're taking on a
crazy amount of debt we have elections
there's a lot of uncertainty to be
nervous about
but like at a ground level man i'm
pretty bullish
i love it i agree i asked the same two
questions everyone before i finish up
and you'll get to ask me one first is uh
what's the most important book you've
ever read
ah man i i love so many uh books about
entrepreneurs but um
i would go back to one my dad gave me
when i was a teenager in the seven
habits of highly successful people i
just think it's like
it's super basic advice but it grounds
you and and there are things in there
that you'll learn and live by the rest
of your life
it's timeless because it works right and
and it's just there's so many times when
i think back to there's an example in
that book of
you know a guy on a subway or a bus and
his kids are acting up and
you know people around him are looking
at him like your kids are
you know we are a bad parent and then
somebody
realizes that his wife had just passed
away and so
having the compassion to think about
what other people are going through
particularly in a time like we're in
right now
it's just a this it's a timeless lesson
right we have people out here preaching
all these things like do this do this do
this but they don't understand the
circumstances that other people are in
so there's just there's a lot of
timeless lessons in that book
yeah i love that uh the second question
is more fun aliens
believer or non-believer
i think you know if you think back to
like christopher columbus
landing in america and thinking that he
was in india
like throughout history we've
underestimated
what was beyond us and so i think the
idea that we think we're the only ones
is just kind of crazy i don't
you know i don't believe there's like
aliens in my neighborhood but like i do
believe there are other life forms out
there
and so i think you'd be crazy if if you
don't believe that then you kind of
don't believe in research and technology
and science
and all the things that have been
progressing our world forward i don't
know what about you
oh i definitely believe i was going to
be shocked if somebody who believes so
much in the technology and innovation
didn't believe in aliens right yeah i
mean i don't think like
you know i don't i don't think i'm like
hanging out with him next to him at the
grocery store but i think we'd be
incredibly naive to not think i think we
figured it all out
yeah and and i also think it's uh it's
not like hard to understand kind of
what's possible
it's also just hard for us to fathom the
things we do know right i
always say like everyone you know thinks
of aliens as something that is
let's say in space there's a lot of
stuff we don't know about our own oceans
right so we kind of like put that in
relationship they think okay we kind of
have this idea of how big
the galaxy is for example right but like
we just know it's
big but when you hear the numbers you're
like okay like i have no
you know kind of comparison point to
understand how big that really is
right and so when you start to hear
things like um i think it was uh
neil degrasse tyson said that like
in order to reach some parts of uh
certain planets
you would basically have to put children
on like you know newborn children
on a spaceship send them teach them
everything while they're in
flight then they would have to have like
grandkids at some point and then
those grand can get eventually like
reach a planet right
and it's like okay that seems pretty far
like those rockets seem to go pretty
fast so
right it's just kind of crazy now i'm
not willing to go as far as elon musk
saying we're living in a simulation
although i do love his theory
um i just think it's crazy to assume
like if you assume we figured everything
out
like that's a that's a tough way to go
through life yeah depressing like like
be an optimist
like nobody thought we could land a
rocket we could shoot a rocket into
space and landed on a little platform in
the ocean and then he did it everybody's
like
oh yeah like that took what 50 years of
space travel to figure that out and then
somebody figured it out so it's like
i don't know and it's part of what makes
life great like there's new things you
discover and learn and so i just
like you know do i want to go hang out
with aliens not necessarily but do i
believe there are people out there yes
i i i uh i think i see eye to eye with
you at all
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me so you
you meet some incredible people through
this process and doing all the
conversations that you have what's
i don't know what's one big takeaway
you've had over the last year or two
from some of the smartest people you've
interacted with and i've listened to a
lot of your
your episodes i mean just incredible
diverse personalities that you've had on
from
you know dave portnoy to jim cramer to
uh
michael saylor uh what what's like what
what pops into your mind like something
you've learned from all of that
a takeaway maybe you didn't have a year
or two ago
here's the scary part is it's not so
much things that maybe are like
groundbreaking
it's like almost like a return to the
basics right so it's things like
uh the most successful people work their
asses off like i have yet to have
somebody come on and be like
hey guess what like here's the secret
you know i did this one thing
now i'm a billionaire right right
there's not a single person
who who's done that um so kind of hard
work
uh two i would say uh very much like
original thinkers or kind of first
principles thinking
um is very clear when somebody uh has
been able to find
opportunity by using that a third one we
were talking about this earlier is like
just like the open-mindedness
is very refreshing and i'm actually
surprised usually by
uh how open-minded how intellectually
curious the most successful people are
um they are very much uh
i know nothing teach me right and then
you know kramer was it was a good
example
there's many others um and i think that
maybe the perception of these people
would be like oh they think they know
everything but it's actually the exact
opposite
and the last thing uh is how kind of
compassionate people are
right a lot of the enjoyment for me in
the podcast is actually the time before
or after the podcast where i'm kind of
talking about other things
uh and you know during the episodes
there's a lot of kind of focus on
business and investing and
the things that people kind of come to
the podcast listen for but
before and after i've heard incredible
stories
of um you know both things that the
guest has done for their friends or
family or whatever
but also in reverse like they'll say to
me um you know hey here's something that
somebody that's well known did for me
right and uh
you know it's um patrick o'shaughnessy
on his podcast uh the final question
about his last question yeah
yeah it's always like what's the nicest
thing someone's ever done for you and i
love that question because
uh the stories you hear sometimes
i mean there's always like the easy
stuff it's like hey my parents right
like my parents did
everything to get me here um but then
you hear stories of like
whoa that was like way out you know on
the side and and um
you know we saw uh recently ryan
caldbeck
uh came out with uh you know the story
and basically
kind of to your point of like reveals a
whole side of
um you know stress and and obstacles
that he was overcoming
that nobody knew about and i think that
you know your point just on
you never know what people are going
through you you never you know you never
want to assume
things and uh it's a hard lesson to kind
of keep in the back your head but i
think that
again the people who have been the most
successful in life like they've got a
pretty good
um you know grounding in in those types
of principles
the other thing i've learned in the last
five years maybe it's just an age thing
is you can have the flip side of
think of something somebody's done for
you think of something you've done for
someone else you you can have
an outsized impact on somebody's life
by taking an interest taking some
specific actions and following up
and so i've tried to in the last few
years
deliberately pick out a couple of folks
that i thought i could help
and it's been it's been very rewarding
to have them come back to me and say hey
i don't know whether you did this
intentionally or not
but you made an impact and i think if
more
you know if if everyone did that imagine
what would happen
right and so i think there are a lot of
people who do it naturally
but i think when you're maybe in your
mid-30s and early 40s you don't realize
because you're still in that climbing
mode
and now i'm in my later 40s i'm like
well how do i turn around and help some
other folks not like i'm
you know i'm not warren buffett or bill
gates but like there are things that i
can do that can make and
and so when somebody comes back to you
and says hey that was huge it's uh it's
pretty rewarding so i'm trying to
i'm trying to think about how do we
scale that how do we do more of that how
do we encourage more of that
because it's not just philanthropy right
it's behind the scenes at scenes actions
of
actually taking an interest in
somebody's life and trying to help them
be successful
yeah and and i think part of it too is
like it's not just a money thing
right like that's one piece of it it's
literally hey that person who made an
introduction for you that person who
you know responded to an email with a
little bit of advice and
and frankly here's the crazy part is
i've literally
seen um people that i know who pitched a
venture capitalist as kind of an extreme
example
and the venture capital said this is a
dumb idea you're basically wasting your
time
for xyz reason like you you're a smart
person go work on something else
and then they come back and it may take
them a month or two to
kind of realize that but they go hey you
know what like you saved me three years
of running down a path
that ended up like i would have wasted
my time right and there's always this
delicate line of like yeah i would say
that may not be the way to say it but
yeah
and and you know again over generalizing
kind of the the message right but but
it's
this thing of um understanding and being
honest and
and kind of trying to help people i
think that's the thing like genuinely
trying to help people
uh there's the world could do better
having more of it
right yeah and so my thing is how do we
create more of that how do we get
because i'm amazed how i have a lot of
friends who are very successful
who i don't think realize how much they
could do for other people they're like
oh yeah i give
i give money to this i give money to
this and give her this but it's like man
you're you're so good at what you do if
you just took an interest in three or
four people
and tried to help them and and most
people do to your point i think
most people do that um
but i i it's just something i've learned
maybe i'm late to the party like just
taking a conscious interest in some
people on an individual basis
and trying to help them be successful
has been it's been incredibly rewarding
so it kind of goes along patrick's
question of like
you know not because a lot of people you
know like we all like i didn't you know
i didn't start at home plate
like i had a lot of people who helped me
be successful my parents
mentors advisors investors you know
and you sort of look back and i'm always
conscious of telling them hey thank you
you made a real difference in my life
but then you feel like okay i'm now in a
position where i got to do that
so how do i consciously pick some people
and follow up
right not just have that one meeting
where you give somebody some advice
just follow up and say hey how's it
going can i make an intro for you here
can i do this
you know because that person can then
it's just it's such a game changer
right opening doors giving somebody that
extra shove when they need it is such a
game changer
i'm going to leave you with one last
question is dartmouth basketball ever
going to win
fantasy double-a championship ever again
or the first one
we're uh yeah i'd be our first uh
it's gonna be tough we we uh no
someday someday we'll get back i think
um i think
i might get the year wrong i think it
was 1942 dartmouth was in the final four
so i have in my twitter bio you know
working to get back to the final four
but it's
it's been a while but no i love the
program i love the school and i
i i hope we can someday i love i love
sports i love athletics i think it
teaches you a lot of discipline and
and i'm rooting for i'm rooting for the
team so i love it all right jeff listen
thank you so much for doing this i think
people are really going to enjoy it
do it again in the future thanks man